[Music]
thank you for joining us at the nine
days q a and we're going to be talking
about you know the movie and this final
scene
um i'm winston duke i play will in the
movie and we have edson oda who is the
incredible director of the piece
and we have spike jones our executive
producer this scene is the last scene of
the
film it's the climax and it's it's one
of my favorite scenes and so if you
haven't seen the movie i recommend
stopping watching this
watch the film then watch this again
because you're going to want to watch
that scene twice anyway and for those of
you that already watch the movie here's
the scene again and then we'll be right
back
[Music]
have you ever reckoned the earth much
spend this day
and night with me
and you shall possess the origin
of all poems
i
i celebrate myself
and sing myself
and what i assume
you shall assume for every
atom
belonging to me is good belongs to you
i loaf and invite my soul
i lean
and i loaf at my ease
observing
a spear
of summer grass
ah
my tongue
oh
every asom of my blood
born
here
from parents born here
and their parents the same
as their parents the same i now 37 years
old and in perfect health begin hoping
to cease not till death
the smoke of my breath echoes
ripples
buzzed whispers
crotch
and vine
my inspiration and
respiration the passing of air
and blood through my lungs the sound of
the belch words of my voice
[Music]
[Applause]
loose to the eddies of the wind
a few light kisses
[Music]
a few embraces
the reaching around of arms
oh
the play of the light
and shade on the trees
as the supple bows wag
the delight alone
or the rush of the streets
or along the fields and hillsides
the feeling of health
[Applause]
the full noon trill
the song of me
rising from bed and greeting the sun
hey sun
sun
da da da da da sun sun
sun sun sun sun
sun the last sky of sun holds back for
me
it flings my likeness after the rest and
as true as any on the shattered wilds it
coaxes me to the vapor and the dusk
[Music]
i depart as here
i have fused my flesh
in eddies
and drifted
in lacy jags
and to die
[Music]
is different
than anyone supposed and look here
i bequeath myself to the dirt
to grow from the grass i love if you
want me again
look for me under your boot soles
[Music]
you will hardly know who i am or what i
mean but i shall be good health to you
nevertheless
failing to fetch me at first
keep encouraged
missing me one place
search another
[Music]
i stop someplace
waiting for you
uh
thank you
i'm so glad you picked this scene this
scene is so radical and um
i remember when when we first talked
about it after i saw the film edson i
asked you about where the text came from
why the text
obviously emotionally it's so perfect
it's so perfect for
for the repression of of winston's
character and the explosion of it and
for everything he's saying about
what he how he wants to live and how he
wants to be seen and
so when we just talk about how you've
how you pick this text and how the text
came about yeah it was interesting
because um
uh when i
that's the part of the movie people say
like the best writing of the movie and i
didn't write it
you did get some uh you didn't do some
incredible sampling i think i picked
really well yeah so so
yeah and then when it was writing i i
knew
i knew like a moment when uh
real was so scary to become will again
you know and and for me the that should
be like almost like the celebration of
life this kind of uh
uh uh writing that would just translate
what this was going through and then
i remember
uh i'm a huge fan of the this movie
deadpool society yeah and uh there is
this scene there was like um uh ethan
hawk and robert willis talked about the
yap in the off and it's funny because
i'm from brazil so i'm not so familiar
with walt whitman you know but uh but
that scene it was just like you know it
was so inspiring that i just went to
that you know his uh work and his poems
and i found this piece this song like i
saw myself
and there was so much about how it feels
to be alive you know how it feels to be
in touch with nature how it feels to be
in this body you know and i i put in the
script but it never it was interesting
because always for me it was like
attempt
uh writing for me and uh i always had in
mind that uh whoever would play will
uh i would give you know the the the
freedom to just pick something that
would mean something really big for for
for him so and but but that that wasn't
the way it worked but uh i think winston
can talk a little bit about that yeah
for sure it felt like that piece itself
picked us and kept picking us throughout
the entire process because as edson said
he gave me the freedom to choose
something that i had more of a
relationship with he you know he came to
me said i know you come from theater and
so feel free to bring in any monologue
from any play or anything like that
because it's really about
the character expressing something
that's very close to him so if it's
close to you it's close to will
i scoured i think shakespeare chekov you
know we brought in the seagull
august wilson we looked at you know a
lot of different plays from august
wilson and we just kept coming back to
song of myself you know at the end of it
i just said i think this is just the
thing we got to do and i did it one time
fully for edson and he you cried
i remember that day yeah we had a
rehearsal rehearsing was a big part of
our process
and edson was in tears and he said we
have to use the poem this is it i didn't
expect that it would really be the thing
but it's the thing can i ask you both
because i love the text so much and
i will you both
quote your your not even your favorite
one of the parts that just jumps to your
head right now
ah
so many of them i would say
um
i keep
i keep sending flowers and they keep
sending pigs to eat them
he he was just being kind he just like
uh oh yeah he that wasn't from the
moment
without the mother i gotta just give
like a line from nancy's you know right
now but actually that line actually it's
not from this scene but it it is a scene
it is a line that really encaptures your
character and the film's the film's fear
of being deeply in love being deeply in
love with with life and existence and
and
and
interaction with human beings
i think that's
that's the main fear you know i always
say that
i spent the entire movie playing
will's shadow
i played the parts of will that
most of us don't want to show it's it's
painful it's dark
and
that monologue is his light you know
most of us it's it's light it's it's
it's where most of us
wish to interact with each other
day-to-day so and the thing that the
thing that is hard to do you know it's
hard to live that way because you know i
think it's it is easier to live
tight or shut down it's easier to live
cynically it's easier to live scared
but it's also a sad way to live because
you're not actually without the risk you
don't get that electricity of what being
alive is that line yeah that line you
coded was actually edson's line but
what's what's a line from the monologue
that and this is partially just
selfishly because i love hearing your
voice in the monologue
you should stay in the voice my favorite
one is the the ending always
is
um
you'll find me there waiting
so when when i'm gone
and you know i'm in i'm a part of the
i'm a part of the grass and all those
things
look behind you you'll find me there
waiting which is this beautiful way of
like no one really leaves us
no one's ever really gone because
they're all a part of
the cycle you know which is
that's that for me was my favorite
aspect it always it always chokes me up
yeah
i i feel that i feel that from that
scene and that that whole movie it sort
of
undulates with that and uh
edson what's up what's what's part of
the monologue that jumps out at you that
i i think it's not specifically a line
but it's a moment when
uh winston's is yelling
and sassy joins him in the l
is just you know he's leading it's
almost like a dance it is advanced the
two of them are like
alive together i think what winston was
doing he was the lead the best lead
leaders and like when they danced
they invite someone to make the movement
or something so it was interesting
because winston was just always
inviting
and giving like you know zazi like a
a space
that yale was just like uh okay i'm
yelling here
and then this as he just joins that you
know
playful you know moment and then the the
the composer just such a terrific job
adding like a third voice and that so
for me it was it was very powerful
like are you are you sort of out of your
body in that like doing that are you
even conscious are you making decisions
are you just completely
surrendered and like
that's a lot of both there's a lot of
work that i put into
um working on
that
part of the script
for the entire time that you know ever
since i got the job
which is like looking it over breaking
down each line making each line
into sentences i went back into
the entirety of of of the poem because
it's much longer than what we have
he's talking about being
completely present so it was really
figuring that out doing all that work
i got to the the desert and i remember
just praying and i said i'm here
i
stuck my hands into the the dirt
to feel it
and that's when it all finally clicked
like all that work came together
when i stuck my hands
in the dirt and i said ah
and that's when the real surrender
happened
you know
the desert was the final character that
was the final scene partner that's when
you turn off and say okay the work's out
the window
let let the desert and zaci
give me everything i need
and it all became this like cool alchemy
for for for a small moment until sunset
beautiful
beautiful yeah there's a there's a i
asked it kind of that's what it felt
like it felt like incre it felt like
there's a quote i think it's charlie
parker who says learn everything and
then forget it all
and it felt like that i have a question
in terms of winston like this is
edson's first movie were you nervous at
all working with him as a first-time
director did you know he was going to be
this
this clear this intentional and what was
that like
yeah i feel like i got a really great um
insight to the type of director he was
because he is
a writer director the script itself told
me everything i kind of needed to know
about my director
i was like wow this is the guy right
and then once we had our three-hour
conversation where we pretty much didn't
even talk about
the movie
i think we spent 30 minutes of that time
talking about the movie
and we talked as people otherwise
talked about
star wars talked about anime we talked
about being immigrants we talked about
how similar
being an immigrant from brazil is to
being an immigrant from trinidad and
tobago
what it feels like to be an outsider
and it was like those things kind of
just told me the kind of human being and
then that i was going to be dealing with
um and then once we show once i was on
set
you know the thing about edson is that
he's really clear about the world that
he's creating so
it felt like a person who's been
directing for a long time
you know what i mean thank you because
he knew his vision he had a clear vision
of what he wanted to accomplish and he
understood
explain it
do the work
surrender
let us perform
thank you that's cool and
it's and i i know how personal the film
is to you and the film is you know
something you've worked on for years and
years and
uh
writing about your uncle and writing
about your understanding of
his passing and
how did you know that winston was the
right one
to carry that spirit
first he said something that for me was
so
when you were just talking about why you
make movies you want to make people who
feel invisible not to feel invisible to
not to be invisible to give a voice and
i think that was
so much how i think
my uncle felt you know
and how you know i i feel when i connect
to him uh i feel invisible
i knew from from our conversation that
he
he wouldn't judge who my uncle was or
who
i am sometimes when i become my uncle
sometimes and
i used to judge that a lot it was to
feel like i can't be like him you know
and even when sometimes i am like him i
feel like hey i can hate that part of me
you know
and uh i think
you can't do that i knew he wouldn't do
that and he would be really fell in love
with the character so it was very
meaningful and and then second was just
uh he was the will of the end of the
movie you know
that you know winston he can just light
the room with his energy with his joy
which is you know
and and i knew that
i i as you say i just need to sit you
know above him and just don't let it
just like somehow
put a roof and just like you know press
him down
and then by the end just you know let me
go because then it was more like about
how could i communicate with him
for him to just uh hide that will
so it's more like a casting for what he
will will be
it was like a pressure cooker it felt
like
winston is there anything else you'd
like to add or anything do you want to
you want to bring us out with your
beautiful voice
oh no it's just you know i hope that you
guys enjoyed nine days this was
a passion project for everyone involved
spike can speak to it is it becomes a
passion so i hope that everything that
we've poured into it has
kind of been transferred into your lives
from watching it and
after we're we've left such a year of
not having
human connections in the same way and
now appreciating them in a different way
i hope that this movie speaks to people
where they're at
and thanks for watching
thank you edson and winston i send you
both love and i look forward to all
being in the same room together yeah
thank you so much thank you
thank you